so I don't own an Xbox one or ps4 and in
fact when they were first announced I
wasn't immediately jumping on the
pre-order wagon like so many others but
it isn't my first choice of next-gen
consoles to buy either because I have
run into so many problems when using
them here in the office for one
particular job I had to install some DLC
for Call of Duty ghosts and it took no
fewer than six or seven hours or so to
the point where a live stream ran late
and it was was embarrassing for me and
something that I wasn't expecting
in fact I even had one friend call me
saying I've just bought an Xbox one and
a port Forza and has taken hours almost
days to install what am I doing wrong
and I just had to tell him buddy that's
that's what it does that's that's an
Xbox so I picked up an Xbox one a few
months after its launch right before the
initial price drop actually but I still
find it was worth it for me because I
love forts and if anybody loves forts of
join system you can play it on and Wars
horizon - phenomenal - and it's totally
worth it for those two games alone in my
opinion along with all the other games
you to play being a next-gen console
it's been totally unequivocally worth it
even though I can't play destiny with my
friends because they're all in phase 4 I
don't own an Xbox one and I have really
no desire to ever really owned one
purely because there's just nothing
there that interests me in terms of the
games in terms of the capabilities of
the console itself I feel like there are
fewer and fewer platform exclusives that
exist even between the ps4 and the Xbox
and that's great because it means you
don't really need to have both to kind
of get the best of what's out there at
the moment and currently what's on the
ps4 and what's on but we you serve my
interests far more than anything that's
on the Xbox one so in all honesty the
only thing that I think is really great
about the Xbox one is its TV integration
you can plug your cable line through it
or you can in the UK you can plug your
coaxial cable through it it just makes
it a bit more easier to use and a bit
more I don't know a bit more convenient
and fun
I use it frequently but I don't use it
frequently to play games it's sort of my
go-to media device and part of the
reason for that is is that it's easy to
just as soon as as soon as I get home if
I want to watch some Hulu or Netflix
which is typically something I tend to
do I already know the things to say out
loud the minute I walk in the door to
boot them up so I can just walk in the
door I mean it'll see Xbox on and 75% of
the time it'll actually turn on or I'll
say Xbox on again and eventually it'll
it'll be on typically that's what I use
it for because I talk to it and it
listens sometimes the voice commands are
helpful even though you kind of have to
speak like you're reprimanding the Xbox
in order to get it to work saying like
Xbox go to blu-ray player doesn't really
work but if you say Xbox go to blu-ray
player it works just fine I'm not a fan
of the Xbox ones interface I find it I
think it I think it's just
actively out to get me it's not it
doesn't make sense to me it's not easy
to find things although when you plug in
the Kinect and you can just say Xbox go
to settings that's great I love doing
that but why can't I do that and
navigate it myself using a controller it
just doesn't make sense to me so the
interface is a stupid mess it's more
designed to advertise things to me than
it is to actually let me do the things I
want the experience of sitting down with
an Xbox one I don't find particularly
enjoyable I find it clumsy confusing
snap is not something particularly
intuitive and just even getting into the
settings and changing things around
really frustrating though your hand on
hardly honest truth is that the
operating system and the UI is so bad I
actually find it quite fascinating like
every single bad decision I find quite
fascinating that that was that was
agreed upon at Microsoft that they they
thought that it was a good idea I think
I really mean that the interface is
atrocious and I am genuinely shocked and
fascinated by the fact that it's
it's available and it was considered
ready so need to be almost like a
perfect storm of reasons for me to
change my mind actually you get an Xbox
one I think it would need a couple of
massive exclusives say The Witcher 3 was
only on Xbox or say no man's sky was
only on Xbox paid games like that which
I want to play that coupled with some
sort of another price drop coupled with
a completely new UI then I would
probably buy one
I mean controversially there some times
where a game performs better on a ps4
and then I'm super jelly that I can't
play it at the right you know at 60
frames per second that sucks
but I think that those are trials that
will get better with time I think the
Xbox one is an awesome console and I'm
really excited for more exclusives to
come I mean obviously you buy those
things for like the halo Master Chief
collection and it's awesome for that and
I think they'll be more exclusives
coming up in the next year that'll make
it just as awesome and give me more
bragging rights so hurry up and bring
them out because I feel like I'm getting
made fun of in the office